welcome back to another gadget lab
podcast I'm Mike Isaac I'm let the glory
and I am back in town from San Diego
last week I was at a CGI a mobile
conference oh it was quite possibly the
most boring thing I've ever been to in
my entire life did they serve ice cream
they had no they annoy scream they had
crappy deli meats that kind of like
started sweating in the heat of San
Diego but other than that I mean that
conference sucked but I am back so and
we've got a week full of news as always
a tale about the first thing is a
reading ice cream there that's a good
segue there is ice cream actually google
finally debuted android 4.0 ice cream
sandwich which is the next generation of
the android software for google's for
mobile phones so this this brings like
the Google tablet interface and the
google phone interface together right
right basically google has had a
difficult time i mean their software is
on a billion different you know
manufacturers tablets a billion
different manufacturers phones and
people writing code for the hardware
don't know basically how to fit it all
on to the number of different screen
sizes out there right which is different
from Apple who which has only you know a
handful of devices so with android 4.0
they basically yet they took both the
tablet and the phone interface and
combined it into one magical tasty
android big sandwich of creamy and
already goodness haha so anyway what's
the cool stuff in it it was rad it was I
went down to Google on Wednesday of this
week and they showed me the debut device
the flagship device that they so as you
know every new version of Android they
launched with the specific phone right
right so this time with Samsung's Galaxy
Nexus which is it was a cool phone like
I got it I finally got to play with it
before it comes out and no
number and it's like a big it's a big
sort of four point I believe 4.65 inch
screen yeah pretty big lid right super
amoled you know its LTE 4G so it's
actually going to be a fast they're not
saying what carrier quite yet but well
what are the possibilities and pretty I
mean obviously Verizon t-mobile t mobile
tmobile might be I mean t-mobile has
been the Nexus warn the nexus s they
first known that but I'm if its 4G then
then it's probably going to be verizon
or AT&T or maybe sprint ok anyway so but
the hardware was less compelling to me
than the software honestly it was
basically every complaint you always
hear about Android being sort of rough
around the edges or not feeling as good
as iOS they they kind of focused on that
the team sort of basically polished
every little thing from changing the
dafont right to they created their own
font they made Roboto which is so
controversial which this is actually
getting a lot of attention to this right
it is it's a mishmash of other fonts
they ripped off Helvetica yeah I'm like
that right whatever that's for the font
nerds I'm so they did that and then you
know they they did away with the
physical buttons on the phone so they
have these sort of virtual buttons on
the phones now kind of like they did in
honeycomb and they made a lot of sort of
tweaks to the different Google private
area applications they really just it
was a really big overhaul and then one
of my favorite things or to my favorite
things actually one was this they have
this feature were with uses it's called
face unlock right so my phones walked
and I want to unlock it i can set an
option to make it recognize my face
using this facial recognition technology
in order to unlock my phone so what if i
just like hold up a picture of your face
i asked him that he said he said it's
kind of imperfect right now that might
actually work so they're kind of in the
beta stages of more
the king salmon well I'm not really that
worried about somebody walking around
with a full-size and out of my face just
they can get into my phone you are on
podcast weekly you never know how many
people out there save you but that's
true freeze frame yeah so aside from
aside from all the issues with ice cream
sandwich and that new phone there is
still another carrier and I'm sorry not
carrier phone manufacturer out there
treading their own waters yeah which is
nokia or how's that what do they say
they've Nakia Nakia like w this is this
is a brand new nokia phone and what does
it run for operating system so this runs
the Harmattan built on top of me go
which is a linux based platform that a
source open source it's the problem is
it's it's it's not Nokia's future right
they had already nokia and microsoft are
working together to bring Microsoft's
Windows Phone 7 platform to future nokia
phones we're probably going to see one
next year something like that maybe soon
nokia world's coming up is I can happen
in Europe before it happens in the
United States maybe maybe they test it
out over there and see how it does and
then bring it over here but anyway this
doesn't have that this has a software
that essentially has a very dated shelf
life you know over the next but so I
mean that was my main sort of quibble
but it's actually kind of a nice phone
like there's it's got some sort of webos
type characteristic you can open up
applications and then swipe them to the
phone yeah I notice there's no real hard
buttons on the screen right also a
buttonless phone it's kind of I mean if
you're used to Android or iOS excandesco
a little bit of a learning curve but uh
you know I mean I also like the sort of
industrial design of it it's it's cute
right it looks like a giant yeah this is
not a case this is actually there the
shoulder all right exactly i can believe
this it comes in what's cyan and then
magenta and black all process colors wow
that's interesting is there is there a
clear version Garrett there's not
well you know I think with things like
this it's kind of interesting because
you know yeah you're not going to have
the the great rich app story behind it
to sell people on but if you want just
like a really good smartphone from a
company that's proven itself to be a
powerhouse it's a good choice and as far
as the learning curve goes it's a kind
of thing where Android there's so many
skins on Android I kind of feel like
there's a learning curve even when you
pick up an android phone from a
different manufacturer as still eat your
rice totally true you have to learn all
over every time yeah so anyway you know
if you are into learning something new
and don't mind your phone being outdated
in a few months I would say go pick one
up otherwise I don't know maybe you only
care about Apple right if that's the
case we have Christina Christina
Bonnington is up next to talk about the
world of Apple and all that's going on
this week hey Christina hey Mike so
what's new in Apple's world this week so
first off the iphone 4s is going to be
coming to a fourth carrier here in the
US Oh t-mobile nope c spire wireless
it's a carrier thats how is that it's a
regional carrier they're actually I mean
a lot of us haven't heard of it they're
based in the south mostly like
Mississippi Tennessee Alabama and
Florida oh that's really weird why is
Apple moving to like what is the why
wouldn't they move to t-mobile why they
moving so it's a c-spot with southern
wireless carrier well I mean to hit the
Texas demographic yeah actually it's
more texts but I'm from Texas so no
offense yeah well I am doing so no yeah
and I also lived in Mississippi I've
been all over but anyways so I mean
there's a couple good reasons why Apple
probably brought it down to c spire
wireless um first off kind of t-mobile
covers a lot of the same areas that
eighteen t Verizon Sprint already do
okay um so they might be trying to reach
a demographic that
may not already have easy access to the
iphone that make sense um and then it's
also they're cdma okay all right well I
mean that kind of makes sense but do
they have the even the similar sort of
subscriber subscriber base that t-mobile
does you know i mean i know t mobile's
is dwindling but mm-hmm they I mean they
are the eighth largest carrier in the US
so I mean it's not it's not tiny right
but I mean yeah it's interesting that
they chose it's just a weird thing to
hear like Apple choose the ceasefire yr
anyway what again so wait for that
Tennesseans or whoever you said is going
to get it there's something else going
on to you you had a post about how
tablet at what is it and how we're not
going to see a seven inch apple tablet
something right so I mean what inspired
this I mean have people been waiting for
a seven inch apple tablet so there's
been rumors that there could be an ipad
mini a seven inch ipad for a while I
mean there were some back before the
ipad 2 even came out but recently since
the amazon kindle fire came out there's
been different comments that you know
apple could be coming out with a budget
ipad or a smaller ipad one analyst said
set this whole thing calling it an ipad
mini and so that sparked all those many
analysts make up names for apple
products yeah i actually use that as my
signature on my iphone for my iphone
mini i've had many I mean yeah but so
you don't think there's gonna be I mean
you don't think there's gonna be right I
think anything is possible but I think
it's pretty unlikely okay um you know
you want to avoid that fragmentation
problem that Android has had a problem
with trying to code for all these
different sized devices you want to
optimize as a developer the UI for your
device and so Apple has to 3.5 inch
iphone ipod size screen right and a 9.7
inch ipad if you add a 7-inch one in
there you know developers have to you
know revamp their app for this yeah that
just makes creates a whole new slue
problem okay that's I mean that makes
sense I guess although I mean it's only
one
more thing but still because Apple up
what Apple would be following kindle or
amazon's lead here right and you said
that's not like them at all um listen
earthquake earthquake I think we just
went through an earthquake awesome well
we're okay so anyways keep going yeah so
the amazon kindle fire broke out you
know this 7-inch tablet that everyone's
excited about Melissa I talked to said
that a lot of people are more excited
about the low price point than the
actual 7-inch tablet size which is
possible its butt and then also Steve
Jobs said that seven inches is just too
small for a good tablet experience okay
well I'm sorry I'm distracted because we
apparently just had an earthquake in
California which is kind of awesome but
uh we're going to see you guys next week
possibly well probably with more apple
rumors and with the sort of a first look
on androids ice cream sandwich